Hey youtubers it's Charlie.
So this is going to be my Agents Of SHIELD
Episode 6 video.
We actually got to see a couple of big Comic
Book Characters
we saw the Marcus Scarlotti Whiplash whose
from the Iron Man comics.
and we got to meet Ward's Brother.
Not necessarily a comic book character.
Even though they did put the Alien Writing
storyline on the back burner, we did get a
big WTF at the end.
If you didn't recognize him, he was Brian
Van Holt from Cougar Town.
So I did laugh my way through that end credits
scene just a little bit.
I know I also promised to do a Q&A about the
big Marvel Phase 3 announcement, so I'll answer
a bunch of
questions
about it
after I
get
through SHIELD.